hey welcome to the Reuben report i'm
dave rubin this is YouTube we gotta move
I've got Cara Santa Maria and Jen
Hoffman with me and it has been a week
of scandals and it's going to be
probably a month the scandals and
perhaps a year of scandals there's
somebody to choose from between the AP
IRS Benghazi everyone has a favorite and
Newt Gingrich who no one listened to
when he was running for president said
this week that the GOP may be over
playing their hand when it comes to all
this scandal stuff basically because
people still seem to like Obama and
Hillary Clinton more than the GOP
themselves so ladies do you have a
favorite scandal and which scandal could
it possibly be Karen like a favorite
currents a favorite could not scandal
you know what you can get either however
you want to take that I left it open
ended for you um right well I missed a
weird question asked hey what's my
favorite scan it could be a personal
skin well I go if I'm gonna look through
the three choices that you just met
before I think I don't say it's my
favorite that's a super weird way to say
it but I don't really think benghazi I'm
still unsure as to whether or not that
is a scandal at all okay so obviously my
phone on action fox news then right
exactly you're watching that's the
biggest scandal ever but that's just
basically like because that's again
exactly they're making it huge cuz you
know they're making their plan so in
four years they could say oh my god
Hillary Clinton she's so inappropriate
and she sucks and she's a problem it's
not it's not even a thing no one really
cares it's like a it's like a thing we
don't know who drink about yeah what you
said I mean I think in some ways and I
think Newt is on to this it's actually
making them look bad right you know what
I mean it's making the GOP look this is
why Obama's numbers haven't changed his
polling data hasn't changed at all
because I think people are still kind of
unsure and when they see the GOP like
overblowing it and sort of the the
conservative media overblowing it it's
so obvious yeah it's just too obvious
okay so Benghazi were throwing Benghazi
out okay that's the that's number three
so then addressing them now
okay handling I think someone has to do
it we need it like an official order
otherwise people don't work on I like
favorite you mean like what's the worst
yeah what I think is the most legitimate
okay where's for ya Benghazi do you
think ap or the IRS situation the IRS
seems to be the one that today people
are really talking about a lot but what
woody I mean I think from a personal
perspective obviously the AP phone hack
is probably the scariest to a table of
people who probably have worked in
journalism before but the IRS I think a
scandal is probably the most obviously
illegal yeah the IRS one's a little
sexier or more interesting just because
when you find people are being audited
using keywords that's a little bit
scarier because I'm obviously also as
journalist and as people that blog and
of YouTube channels and stuff we're all
using certain keywords out there too so
we can find ourselves on the other end
of that where you know we don't know who
the next president is or this president
or who it's not necessarily either the
IRS works directly for the president
supposed to be separate but that's scary
the implication that if you're saying
things against him that the IRS might
just audit you but I think the AP one is
a little bit scarier because they're
just listening to you and if you're a
journalist you really that's like saying
it's like being in China you know that's
a thing in some other country where you
can't actually have free reign yeah to
you know be a journalist and do your job
ya know we've been talking about this
quite a bit on the show but people don't
realize that the Department of Justice
has already said that they can go into
all of our emails our facebook messages
our twitter dms they're allowed I do
that right now why is it that people
don't seem to care about that no no just
your name no they think it won't happen
to them people have that mentality of
Walter not do nothing wrong then why
does it apply to me right I'm not
planning a you know there's so many
people I think that we may be because
again bring up the journalism thing
we're so used to being conscious of that
and understanding it but a lot of people
think this doesn't involve me why would
they look through my stuff they're not
listening to me they don't care so they
think it doesn't apply to that yeah do
you think people realize how
short-sighted it is to be like well I'm
not doing anything wrong so who cares
a lot of them do I think a lot of
conservatives have a big problem with
this which is strange because it was a
conservative policy that was first put
forth but but I think the real issue
here is that most you know your average
Joe isn't a journalist and doesn't have
sources to protect and I think that
that's the real issue with the AP
scandal is that they're they're certain
there's you know journalistic integrity
that you have to uphold it's part of
your job and it's very important to you
and it's kind of a badge of honor and
it's different if you're talking about
kind of your everyday person who is just
going to work and trying to raise their
family and not involved in maybe sort of
like political things that if we look
into their their doings we're not really
going to find anything and I mean yeah
it is short-sighted to think that way
because you know you give an inch take a
mile oh yeah I think you know it's also
that whole line 11 thing is once you
know the Patriot Act came about people
were for you to say anything about
because terrorism and that just that
word in this country here terrorists
everyone freaks out goes do what you got
to do you don't want terrorism so people
will say great you know audit whoever
has a keyword go through our stuff you
know people really allow access to our
personal information thinking well I'm
not a terrorist I'm not doing anything
wrong i'm not planning anything and
that's just so like just it's such an
ill-conceived idea that you know because
someday you could be just politically
active or sending an email or doing
something and get flag in your but also
it's a generational cap I mean we
weren't around during McCarthyism we
didn't see that happening and we're so
used to social media we're so used to
things like you know Google and Facebook
knowing our preferences and we
appreciate that we want it to autofill
for us we have the nice suggestions it
does make life easier and so we see it
coming from these corporations and I
think it's hard to discriminate the
difference between the Justice
Department doing that you know or
between between the government doing
that and these specific corporations
doing it it's it's a huge gender Demi
not gender a generational difference I
see with my parents for example they
won't use like a credit credit card
online yeah hey well they're they're
really paranoid about credit card it
could be the biggest corporation you
could be like you know Macy's or
something that's been around forever and
they're like well we're not gonna buy
something online because they might
steal our information and I'm like the
Magical Elves stealing your credit cards
that kind of
like our parents generation may actually
be safer in the digital world just
because there's a parent basically when
change occurs you know what your your
kind of uncomfortable with change and
you want to look under every rock and
try to understand it and when you're
born into something when it's kinda I
mean I wasn't born into the Internet era
but you know we're not that you weren't
word out there but but I know people who
were obviously they are around and I had
the internet by the time i was in
college so it is kind of still part of
my DNA all right well we're gonna get
two more social media stuff in a little
bit but final a final point on this how
much do you think because nobody seems
to like the republicans if you look at
the polls it's like their congressional
approval rating is that like six percent
or something so how much of this is just
that they're just throwing anything
against the wall just is this really
just to bang up Hilary cuz I kind of
agree with you this is just to bang
Hillary enough that sounded weird to
just damage her so that at least the
Benghazi and at least Democrats in
general and I think Republicans are
grasping at straws and really as an
in-depth leaning independent but I'm
still an independent at that I wouldn't
have a problem voting for a Republican
that i thought was saying or not making
a sterically everything and I think the
most important thing that Newt Gingrich
said in all this was two things I
haven't heard Republicans saying so long
as he said let's be calm and factual
yeah and for him to say that that's like
that has been so the direct opposite of
what the party and some of their you
know biggest media cheerleaders like Fox
News Fox News they don't like to be
common factual they like to be like
hysterical and is inaccurate as possible
that we are original call you start
going an act that's exactly that was
that
you